this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 500 people to use the link in
the description that get their first two
months free this is Dubai one of seven
monarchies which form the United Arab
Emirates and this is the world a three
hundred island archipelago right off its
coast there's an island for almost
everyone but Israel including California
Antarctica even North Korea you know for
anyone just dying to visit so why draw
the world with 300 million cubic meters
of sand
well why Drive million-dollar police
cars or build the tower so tall you can
watch the sunset right to the top and
watch it again why build a ski resort in
the middle of the desert because well
because they're cool it probably sounds
familiar
a country discovers it's sitting on
black gold and its royalty it becomes
unbelievably rich while the average
person can barely eat but not quite
Dubai
does have oil but today it only accounts
for less than 1% of its GDP what looks
like pure extravagance is actually pure
marketing genius attracting 14 million
international visitors a year who spend
more than any other city in the world 65
percent more even than New York or
London
the Burj Al Arab hotel for example only
has 200 rooms each two stories tall it
wasn't built to make a profit but draw
travelers with deep pockets to its
neighbors Dubai is progressive and
modern to others it's very traditional
and religious it's the pinnacle of
luxury yet many are enslaved living on
next to nothing so how did Dubai become
such an exception
geography is the recipe for civilization
it decides where people can go and what
they can build that's what makes Dubai
so remarkable it's the last place you'd
want to found your city the obvious
reason is climate which ranges from arid
desert to unbearably arid desert the
part of Australia even it kind of just
gave up on and that's well that's it
it rains a whole five days a year with a
hundred and six degree days and 88
degree nights during the winter it drops
all the way to a freezing cold 77
degrees next agriculture or lack thereof
because less than 1% of the country's
land is arable only a third of which is
irrigated large portions are covered in
a salty crust called sabka making it
less than useless for growing anything
but leek players and the entire 3.2
million square kilometer peninsula lacks
a single natural river the United States
in comparison has 250,000 98.8% of
Dubai's water has to be pumped from the
Persian Gulf and desalinated ok so
terrible climate plus poor agriculture
plus no source of the water equals major
international city let's rewind before
it had armies borders or diplomacy Dubai
was ruled by tribes called sheik domes
until the early 1800s when pirates in
the gulf did the unthinkable
they got between Britain and its T
attacking its valuable trade route with
India now the region had strategic value
and they English an excuse to plant
their flag the last thing they wanted
was another tea affair you know you go
easy on them and next thing you know
they want fair and equal representation
it's no good so they proposed a truce
stop stealing our tea and we'll protect
your territory oh and PS were the
captain now
the British settled disagreements
between Sheikh domes now call the
Trucial States and they promise not to
work with any other country which put
them in a strange position on one hand
the tribes were isolated from the world
with Britain as a barrier they struggled
to trade or grow or develop but it also
gave them incredible stability the first
pillar of Dubai's success not a single
leader has been overthrown since and to
this day whenever there's violence or
chaos in the world investors turn to
Dubai for a safe place to put their
money 9/11 for example should have been
terrible for its economy two of the
attackers were from the country and its
banks were used to launder money but
when the US responded with a patriot act
it scared away Arab investors who went
from pumping 25 billion a year into the
US economy to only one point - all that
money was looking for safety and Dubai
was the answer the ultimate test of
stability was the Arab Spring with
protests in Saudi Arabia Egypt Libya
Syria Kuwait Yemen while all these
countries but not the Emirates who sat
with their toes in the sand sipping a
cocktail while their neighbours used a
different kind of cocktail they escaped
revolution because of their unusual
social structure North Korea maintains
stability not because it has the
resources to keep people happy but
because it doesn't need to everyone is
either too preoccupied to revolt or to
isolated to no Dubai is the opposite it
leaves no reason to revolt citizens get
free land water education health care
and subsidized electricity food gas and
weddings it can afford this without the
t-word by carefully managing its
citizenship 85% of the population are
expats compared to say America's 14 you
may have been born in Dubai
you may have lived there 50 years but
you're almost certainly never becoming a
citizen the second pillar is Commerce in
1971 the British decided they had bigger
fish and chips to fry leaving the tribes
to fend for themselves but I ran you
know not wanting them to get lonely
swooped in on the very last day before
they left capturing several Islands the
British cared about as much as a senior
on their last day of school but when
ships arrived on the third island one of
the tribes had an idea hey he looks like
you're admiring this lovely beachfront
property here can we lease it to you for
3 million the Iranians agreed and put
away the weapons they had for some
reason taken to look at real estate the
seven tribes became seven emirates
forming the country we know today and
their spirit of business continued when
iran increased its taxes Dubai lowered
its own and gave free land to any
company willing to move today
Dubai attracts businesses with special
economic zones like Science Park and
media city which has become the middle
eastern hub for journalists and in the
process given to by lots of free press
each zone has different laws a British
court system and uses American dollars
there are almost different countries but
even more important into bhai's plan to
replace oil is tourism long ago the
pearl industry constituted 95 percent of
the Gulf economy until the Japanese
developed artificially cultured versions
devastating Dubai's only income but it
learned the lesson never rely on just
one resource so when it discovered oil
in 1966 Dubai invested the money in
roads factories ports and state-run
businesses before it could become a
tourist destination it needed a way to
get people there luckily Dubai has a
natural advantage conveniently located
between Europe and Asia Africa and
Australia
it began with British airplanes
refueling on their way to India Imperial
Airways paying about a hundred and fifty
dollars a month for landing rights but
Dubai knew it could do better
first it opened its
guys to any airline that would come
later when Gulf Air dropped 45 of its
weekly flights Dubai decided it needed
an airline of its own and that's when it
really took off today Dubai's is the
busiest International Airport in the
world and Emirates the fourth largest
airline by distance travelled Dubai has
plenty of challenges ahead but with
these three pillars its well prepared
for a world without oil its leaders
understand the power of diversifying
your skill set and so should you and I
with skill share you can learn and
master all kinds of creative and
professional skills that will help you
do just that I've created my own course
for anyone interested in learning how to
make animated videos like this one I go
over the research writing animation
everything you need to make a youtube
video from start to finish and what's
awesome is that in the process you're
actually learning many different things
creative writing professional research
graphic design and more I've included
practice files with the course so you
can easily follow along maybe you're
more interested in photography or
investing and Skillshare has those two a
premium membership that gives you
unlimited access to all of them so you
can learn as much as you want and when
you have time but the first 500 people
to use the link in the description get
two months free so you can watch my
course and any number of others at
absolutely no cost
thanks to skill share for supporting
this show and to you for listening
[Music]